[Music]
you know when I worked with Harrison
um 30 something years ago he was already
a huge movie star you know he'd already
done Han Solo it was like this you know
he was there and I was like down there
not that he ever
treated me that way incidentally he was
always very gracious
um but you know uh it it was very
unequal sort of thing but the minute I
got back with Harrison was more on an
equal partnership not I'll never be on
the same level as ours and ever but you
know at least I'd climbed up a little
bit
um your Dame Helen mirror I'm Dave and
I'm damn Helen mirror
and and um
it was just like it was just this
immediate connection it was very it was
very extraordinary and I feel like it it
it it shows on the screen you know there
is this sort of natural ease we have
with each other did you feel that
easiness too yes I did actually
there's a practical person she's a
down-to-earth person she's very very
smart
very astute and she knows her craft so
you basically got Indiana
Jean married and fighting bad guys in
1923's a Yellowstone prequel yeah sign
us up this is the Yellowstone
and you have no rights here how would
you describe the marriage between Kara
and Jacob Denton well you know it's a
partnership isn't it
um
um I call him I say we've lost our
leader you know and he he is the leader
of the family I may be the boss but he's
the leader you know but it's a
partnership and it's an equal
partnership and and I know from my being
with my husband I've been we've been
married now for
forgotten how long we've been married
for but you know quite a long time
that's when you know it's a long time
but I can't remember how many years it's
been
um
but you know it becomes a partnership a
partnership with love but a partnership
um and that's very much where
um you know marriage can be a long a
long process and it has many it has many
phases that it goes through
um but if you manage to you know stay
together through love you know you come
to this very beautiful place where it is
this equal partnership and I think
that's where Cara and Jacob are you have
a long-term partnership as well with
your beautiful wife so was that able to
translate for you and help you in this
Dynamic well I suppose it it helps
but I
I found working with Helen to be
extraordinarily uh easy simple
straightforward there's no
fussiness about her men kill quick with
a bullet or a noose but their fight is
with me what is one thing that you would
like people to take away from their
relationship as they watch the series
that Cara supplies a great deal of
Jacob's strength it was behind every
good man is an even better woman right
I couldn't have said it better that's
certainly the case in my yeah yes but I
don't consider myself a great man but I
do have a great wife as well would you
believe Harrison tried on a 75 different
hats just to find the perfect fit his
character Jacob Dutton is the brother of
Tim McGraw's character from 1883. and
fans can expect plenty of drama when the
series drops Sunday on Paramount plus
tell the world what happens when they
cross me of course the Dutton family is
fighting over land and power but this
time they're also faced with pandemics
drought the Great depression and the end
of prohibition the quality of the
storytelling the quality of the script
the character who I found interesting
and complex there was a special kind of
ambition and energy in this project and
I was attracted to that what was the
toughest part about taking on the role
of the matriarch of the Dutton family in
1923. well nothing was hard actually
nothing was odd the thing that might
have been hard which was would be to
sort of really really deeply understand
the roots and and the and this the
struggle of this character would have
been difficult if we were shooting it in
a studio in Los Angeles
um but we're not we're shooting it on
mountains in Montana and all I have to
do is stand there on that mountain in
minus 25 degree chill factor really cold
and understand
what you know where the the absolute
roots of these characters come from they
come from the land what's next on the
bucket list for you
bucket list oh I'm not visiting the
bucket list I'm still actively working
and uh
I've got a comedy series coming out on
streaming on Apple that I'm very happy
with proud of
I've got a Marvel coming up when will
you know it's time to step away from the
bright lights of Hollywood we don't want
you to but when will you know
I step in and out all the time
you know I have time times when I don't
want to work very much and there are
times when I'm ambitious to get out
there and work
this is one of those
and let us introduce you to the Stars
playing the rest of the Dutton family
James badge Dale Marley Shelton and
Darren Mann either we take this fight to
them oh it's coming us y'all look like
you are an l-o-v-e I mean how fun are
those scenes to shoot together where
he's holding you up in the air and
you're running to him like he's the only
man you've ever seen like it's so
precious yeah it's kind of like a a
little notebook fantasy like when you're
watching it you know you always hope
that you're gonna click well with
whoever is your romantic partner right
but thankfully we knew each other we
were still friends you attack my family
it's gonna be the last thing you ever do
now your overall experience with Helen
and Harrison how would you describe it
uh dream come true you know I grew up
idolizing these people we know they're
amazing actors but getting to know them
has been so special they're such great
people and they set they set such a
great tone from day one this particular
show was super unique one reason is just
the group of people that Taylor shared
and assembled you know he really cast
wonderful human beings as well as
amazing actors
um but also
[Music]
[Laughter]
um but he also right out of the gate he
had us go to this
um Cowboy camp for two weeks and we got
to just immerse ourselves immediately in
ranch life
I've had the time of my life at Cowboy
camp and we it was very bonding
experience because it was all of the
cast who none of us really knew how to
ride a horse minus a few and we were
sore so sore oh my God my growing wanted
to walk out of that you were all dying
inside yeah but when you suffer together
I think it creates an amazing bond
together I said right at the beginning
to Taylor I don't ride I can't ride I've
fallen off holes many times and I'm not
afraid of being on a horse but I don't
know how to ride a horse
so he said don't worry we'll put you in
a buggy
so I got to learn how to write about how
to you know guide a buggy and that was
great I feel like learning to drive a
car really in a way did you gain any new
skills when it comes to working with the
horses uh certainly uh I hope I did
um you know
I have I've owned horses over the years
and I have a home in Wyoming I always
pick up a few things from new people
there was some saddle sore situations
happening for sure also healing that's
because you're riding right now it's an
hour if you ever seen her like Drive
cattle it's unbelievable
so you know they're teaching you how to
ride and eventually they bring out the
cattle and they're like okay now you're
gonna herd cattle I'm always like I got
this i got this and she just comes in
there and it was it was unbelievable to
see this this transition and I found my
passion
[Music]